عملت لاكثر من ربع قرن مستشار استثماراتي
واستراتيجي في روسيا ما الذي توقعته انت
لروسيا قبل عام عندما بدات الحرب
الى شركه توقعنا بانه ستكون
تردي في الاوضاع الاقتصاديه ولكني لطالما
توقعت بان
توقعاتنا انخفاض الحاده كان مبالغ فيها
اولا لان روسيا
اعتادت على التعامل مع العقوبات منذ عام
2014 منذ حادثه القرن فحصل تعديلات كثيره
في الاقتصاد الروسي عبر 8 سنوات الماضيه
وكانوا يستعدون للمزيد من الاكتفاء الذاتي
والتنويعي الاقتصاد
ونشاط الاقتصاديه وخاصه في المسارات
التجاريه على سبيل المثال في عام 2013
قبل بدا العقوبات
روسيا لم تقم ببيع اي نفط او غاز مباشره
الى الصين اما في العام الماضي او قبل عام
من الان الصين كانت اكبر مشتري للغاز او
الروسي خاصه عبر انابيب الغاز الرئيسيه
وكذلك مشترك كبير لالغاز
وفحم والمواد الاخرى
فمساله التنويع حصلت اصلا
فكنا اتوقع انخفاض في الاقتصاد وقد
تفاجاتم
الى اي مدى تحسنت الاداء واعتقد
ان هذا ناجم عن حقيقه ان
روسيا كسبت اموالها اكثر بكثير من التصيد
النفط والغاز والفحم والمواد الاخرى
لان اوروبا بكل بساطه ما عاد تحمل تكلفه
فرضي العقوبات على هذه المواد بسرعه كبيره
لانهم كانوا يعتمدون على روسيا بشكل كبير
جدا وبالتالي سماح حولي الروس لكسب اموال
اكثر ولفترات اطول والحكومه استخدمت هذه
الاموال لدعم الاقتصاد واستدامه النمو
الوظائف وبالتالين
كانت نسبه الانخفاض القلب كثير ما توقحه
الكثيرون